das alibi hat eine nicht identifizierte
weibliche leiche in einem müllcontainer
gefunden
das ist der kann die todesstrafe
vor ihren augen originaltitel secret in
der es um eine kriminalgeschichte auf
der ersten ebene einen mordfall wird
nicht ausreichend geschehen das wird
eine lange zeit und dann macht sich eben
einmal die hauptfigur daran diese
geschichte noch einmal aufzurollen er
hat auch ein europäisches 696.000 weiße
männer an unseren gefängnissen weil man
sich jeden abend 1906 gesichtern sieht
hat man in einem jahr alle durch und das
habe ich getan
13 jahre lang für hauptdarsteller heath
ledger vor ein afroamerikanischer star
der diesen fbi-agenten ray carsten
spielt hat es hier mit zwei frauen zu
tun dass eine widmen die wir gut kennen
als eine über makellose blondine eben
und die auch hier sehr deutlich zeigt
dass sie nicht gewillt ist im alter
konzessionen zu machen
das ist viele rollen nicht unbedingt
zuträglich perfekt ein bisschen weg bloß
natur vor allem auch wenn man sich
ansieht wie julia roberts mit ihrer
rolle umgeht schule robert kennen wir
natürlich 90er jahre pretty woman ja
damals die verkörperung des hollywood
schönheitsideals praxis und bis heute
auch nach wie vor allerdings immer auf
eine weise dass sie durchaus zugibt oder
damit umgeht dass sie inzwischen beinahe
50 jahre alt ist
ich könnte das nicht aushalten wenn er
wieder davon kommt können wir das nicht
etwas weniger offiziell angehen will
gerechtigkeit das bin ich meiner tochter
schon sagen dass sie es gibt einen
moment in dem film wo sie sich auf eine
weise zeigt die fast verblüffend ist
also so ungeschützt ungeschminkt julia
roberts zeigt sich hier in einer
dramatischen weise als eine dramatische
hauptfigur die tatsächlich so etwas wie
gereift ist
allerdings gibt es am ende des films
eine point der erzählerische pointe die
wiederum mit dem hauptthema oder mit dem
dramatischen thema des films zu tun hat
nämlich wer ist für die gerechtigkeit
letztendlich zuständig muss man das
selber übernehmen kann man dem
staatsinstitutionen dem recht das zu
tragen gibt es dann hier eine beute die
dann auch ihre eigene figur noch immer
in ein anderes verhältnis setzt und das
macht den film sehenswert
wir müssen den kampf finden und zwar vor
testen sie wird nicht aufhören
letztendlich ist es kein großes werk der
regisseure rey den man bisher vor allem
aus trieben auto erkannte dann würde ich
jetzt nicht besonders hervorheben wollen
ich glaube auch nicht dass auf dieser
ebene wäre es mit einem film haben zu
tun haben
das amerikanische kino jetzt groß
voranbringt aber als das was er ist eben
ein solides qualitätsprodukt des
hollywoodkinos würde ich doch er kann
seinen namen ändern
wer kann den wagen verschrotten
er kann machen was er will ich finde
hier